this holiday marks the 20th anniversary
of xbox
and the 20th anniversary of halo to our
millions of passionate fans
thank you we wouldn't be here without
all of you
our goal has always been to bring
players together
and for the first time we're thrilled to
offer our entire multiplayer experience
to all players across xbox and pc
with no barriers halo infinite
multiplayer
will be free to play and invite more of
you than ever before
to become a spartan hero
i'm excited to be here with joseph
staton the creative director of halo
infinite
from helping craft the original halo
combat evolved
to leading the fan favorite halo 3 odst
joseph is a halo visionary it is so
great to have him back
with halo thank you bonnie and hey
everybody
for us and i hope many of you halo has
always been about
heroism and wonder about fighting to
keep humanity safe
against impossible odds in a beautiful
and mysterious
sci-fi world this is just one part of
the zetta halo ring
the largest most wide open environment
we've ever built and we can't wait
for you to explore it
the heart of halo is spartan 117
the master chief in the next chapter of
the chief story
you'll face his greatest challenge yet
but
you're not alone in the fight the main
batteries are shut down
we're stuck out here
[Music]
i told you it's enough
so i see
[Music]
i need you to understand
there's not much
[Music]
what happened where is cortana
the rogue ai known as cortana is gone
she's been deleted
how by you of course not
did you hit your head or something don't
you remember
my instructions were to enter this
installation imitate cortana
and lock her down for retrieval yours
were to take her back to the infinity
for deletion
so if it wasn't you
okay then
there's something else on successful
deployment
my deletion routine was supposed to
complete
still here good
good something stopped your deletion
we need to find out why but
this wasn't the mission the missions
change
they always do are you sure
[Music]
of course you can't have a halo game
without multiplayer
and on xbox series x you'll be able to
enjoy infinite's multiplayer action
at up to 120 frames per second finally
i'm very happy to announce
that halo infinite's first free to play
multiplayer season
and infinite story driven campaign will
launch together
this holiday a new day is upon
us a new generation built to fight
together we are unstoppable
are you ready
no scope
killing spree
double kill hello let's do
some damage
skewer acquire
[Music]
claim the enemy flag return it to base
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call at your earliest convenience
now show me what you can do
you